this is a production of cornell
university
thank you very much mark and i hope you
can
all hear me and also see this
presentation uh
thank you for the introduction and uh
also for
inviting me to speak here today it's
only too bad i couldn't be
in cornell in person but that's how it
is right now
so i'm sitting at home right now
in a dark november evening in sweden
in the south of sweden
so the title of this talk might seem a
bit
obscure but the story i want to tell
is about genomic selection basically
and i suppose that
many or most of you maybe are familiar
uh
to some extent with the genomic
selection
but even if you're never heard about
this before i think that
that won't be a problem because this is
not a talk that will be
very heavy on technical details
it's more about what genomic selection
means for practical plant breeding
and also it's a little bit of my
personal reflections
on how genomic selection has been
received and implemented in the
plant-breeding community
and i will show you some examples from
our spring oat breeding program that i
until one month ago was responsible for
now i had another position which is
called group manager population
improvement
and mark described a little bit about
what that was
and i think it will become maybe a
little bit more clear
in this at the end of my talk as well so
i like just mark introduce london a
little bit
uh and i will just
say a few words about the company i work
for it's
it's a pretty big company for swedish
[Music]
in sweden it's an agricultural
cooperative
that is owned by practically all swedish
farmers and 20
000 farmers in sweden all have a share
in this
cooperative we employ about 10 000
people and
work in a number of countries around the
world
and we are as we usually say
uh involved in the entire value chain
meaning
uh from uh the farmer from the seed
up until the consumer products uh the
bread the nutrients the pasta
things like that so we supply the farmer
with what whatever he or she needs in
terms of feed fertilizers
machinery other types of equipment
and consumables and we then buy the
harvest and produce from the farmer and
turn that
into consumer products
and one part of this
company this operation
is plant breeding we have a plant
breeding unit
which is located in here is your map of
sweden and europe
and we are located at the southernmost
part of sweden you can see on the
on the map to the right uh
it's out of the countryside in a little
village called florida
it's a it's an area of
large farms agricultural landscape
glass fields while the rest of sweden is
mostly forested as you might know
so this park looks more like denmark or
continental europe
than the rest of sweden and this is
where
most agricultural activities and
products are
produced and this is also where
most of the well we don't have a lot of
plant-breeding companies actually in
sweden it's we
uh it's us love salmon and a company
called malibu helicopter
eating sugar beets
uh plant breeding in sweden has a long
history actually and
this is a sort of well a phytogenic
decree you could say of
150 years of swedish plant breeding
it started in solid in this little
village
in the 1870s or 1880s
where uh some large farmers um
got together and thought that we need
better seeds let's
start some kind of sandwiching
activities here
so they established uh something called
a swedish student association
and they had a company and then
swallows quickly became
quite an active and important center in
early plant breeding and genetics
research
and we have do we've been doing plant
reading since
then under different names and with
different
owners for a while the company was known
as foreign as mentioned
now we are part of this big landscaping
group
a small unit in a big company it has its
advantages and it's just advantageous
that's the way it is
but we have this long long tradition
of plant breeding which we can grow up
on
today uh we have been breeding over the
years
about 50 or 60 or so different crops
today
we do cereals wheat barley oats and
critical
we do spring oyster grape or canola
we have a number of orange grasses and
legumes
and also flava beans and we have
potatoes
and we have willow's song bioenergy
tree that we breed and we will
soon start also repeat reading program
and you see as you can see here these
are all crops that have
different modes of reproduction and
different genetics some are ingrid lines
some are hybrids some as different
are not pure lines but history genius
populations
and some are clonally propagated and
usually highly heterozygous
by this like potatoes for example for
these in terms of genomic selection
and the development of prediction models
they all have
their own challenges so it can be quite
demanding to
to sort of apply genomic selection in
this
rather diverse set of crops
but this is what we try to do
sorry
now if you would ask someone
to mention or name the most important
milestones in the history of plant
breeding
you would probably come up with
something like this this is from
the west side of euro seed european seed
association and this starts all the way
from
you know the domestication and then you
have different crops were domesticated
you have an ambulance you have hybrid
bleeding and you have
mutation breathing and genetic network
selection and gmos
and gene transfer and all that this is
all very well and important
steps in the history of plant breeding
but i if you ask me i would argue that
there are only three
really important uh
milestones in the history in the modern
or recent history of plant breeding
since the discovery of mendel's
walls and this is my own personal view
of the history of plant breeding since
the 1880s or so
the first event
was what i call fans reading 1.0
and that was the idea of the concept of
concept of individual plant selections
as opposed to
mass selection in land races
there was a breeder in swallow actually
called the albanian
who in 1896
thought that it would be better too
instead of
doing mass selections in very diverse
populations
isolate individual plants and
propagate offspring from individual
plants
and in this way to develop inward
pure lines he worked with cereals
this was sort of in anticipation you
could say of johansson's theory
of inward lines and concepts of the gene
type and the phenotype
which came from years later and this
turned out to be really successful
they developed many new varieties
very good varieties using individual
plant selection
the next milestone was not long
after that when a guy called the armani
well invented or thought that
it would be a good idea to do
cross-breeding to cross
plants in order to obtain
[Music]
superior recombinant genotype
and of course he grew upon the theory
of mendel that was had just
been discovered some years earlier
and he was strongly influenced by you
know eric chermax and cole korens and
those who discovered
mendel's works they actually visited him
in scholars
and he got to learn from them and he
became one of the
most prominent genetic researchers in
the early
20th century and was also ahead of the
breeding
in florida and he
was one of the first who could show that
continuous traits
or quantitative traits have a mendelian
basis
so he introduced cross-breeding and that
was very controversial at that time
because people thought
that oh you just create chaos if you try
to cross plants and you
god knows what you will find in our
screen but of course that turned out to
be
really successful as well
and it's now of course an established
mode of work in plant breeding
uh and then
not what happened actually in implant
breeding
until around 2010
when genomic selection was introduced
and of course it's hard to put a year on
that because it's a process
but i would say around 2010 it was has
had become sort of accepted
in a sense in the cloud breeding
community
and that sort of ushers in the era of
plant breeding
that i call trans plant reading 3.0
and to my mind this is the first
really transformative
change in how
we do plant breeding since the
introduction of cross breeding
i would say it's more important than for
example in synaptic transformation
or mutation breathing or hybrid breeding
because it changes fundamentally the way
that we approach
or think of sound breathing i will try
to explain what i mean by that
um
and i think uh
yeah and in 2014 i don't see this myself
in 2014 we we established an oath
3.0 that's when we started to do genomic
selection as a
routine routine method in
in our spring of reading program
and if you actually look at uh
what i call plant prison 2.0
uh on the right hand side you see a
dramatic illustration of a pedigree
breeding
setup for sales and crop from a 2015
book
and on the left-hand side you see
something
that looks pretty much the same it's
from
swish uh drawing from this guy
from als from 19 or 12. you can see that
in many respects not what have happened
since since plant reading 2.0 started
in the early 20th century
if you look at how breeding of stalking
crops
looks today or up until today at least
this is how plant green 2.0
typically looks in a in a cereal crop
self-imperial crop
to the left you see a picture an image
of some small plots in a field
these are the early generations in this
case
s4 generation and perhaps you can see
that there are
five rows in that little cloth
and each of those rows is one
uh inbred it's on cell plane ranges and
f4 but
still on its way to be in red line
we treat them as separate lines and you
have about
some 20 or 30 000 of these lines in the
field
and typically in the early generations
of a breeding program we have about ten
to the fourth ten to the five different
lines of the unit types
and you have usually have very little
fee of each so you plant them
you have them you keep them at single
plants or in rows like this
and then what happens is that
as you go through the generations you
discard about 99
of your line until you come to the
advanced generation
which they maybe is or so
when you're down to 10 to the second
genesis or about 100
or so maybe a few thousand different
genotypes that you can plant
big plots in
several sites with replications over
several years
and that allows you of course to
estimate phenotypic values
with the greater precision than is
possible
in the earlier generations however
it is in the early generations that you
have to do most of your selections
you have to throw away 99 of your line
and usually uh that is made
the selection decision is also made
purely on a
by this visual inspection so i would
in this case this is oats you can see
here so i would walk up and down these
these rows in the field and just look at
the plants or the rows and say that
this row i want to keep in this row and
throw it away and this everything
looks good and for the more or less hope
for the best but this is the way that
i would say the majority of planned
parenthood work today
uh basing
early selection on uh some kind of
visual
evaluation of a small step
of plants or a small number of plants
which is something
particularly genotype
now a couple of years ago then or it's
now six years ago we
we asked ourselves how efficient is this
really how how good is this early
selection that we use
so we decided to do a little experiment
we sent out the breeder in the field and
that was me to
pick out the best lines the best rows
and then we just selected the same
number of rows by
randomly and then we
eventually they ended up in these field
trials like the ones you can see on the
right
and we could evaluate my selection
versus a random selection and
surprise surprise there was absolutely
no difference
between reader selected lines
and randomly selected lines for a number
of
important traits economically important
traits our main breeding goals
grain yield volume weight of the grain
the grain weight uh
and grain size there was no
significant difference at all at all
between the breeder and the random
purely random selection in some cases
the random selection was actually better
than a green installation
so this was well i mean
i had expected this to happen
but it was sort of scary
and encouraging at the same time to see
this i was afraid i would
be fired of course after this
but when you see this and you conclude
that
the breeder has no ability at all
to to be sorry
to do a better selection than a few
random selections you have two options
basically either you carry on with
random selection you just generate
random numbers in an excel sheet and
that's very cheap
and straightforward and you don't have
to have any particular confidence to do
that
or you can try to improve your selection
methods
and we tried to improve our selection
methods uh
of course and this is how we uh started
to implement genomic selection enough
to to increase the selection accuracy in
early generation
and this is also where the plant's
reader's equation
again comes in and if you need to be
reminded of this of that
the previous equation describes how
the mean of a trait changes
as a result of selection so you will
have
a starting population with some
distribution
or some trait value a value for some
traits
and then you select the best ones or you
can also select the worst ones
for the lowest one that you select the
top ones
or the green portion here and you
intermediate all those individuals in
that green portion
and if you measure then the offspring
uh the collective offspring from that
those intermitting you will find that if
the trait is heritable it will have
shifted
the mean will have increased uh
and the the
magnitude of that increase in relation
to the magnitude of the selection
differential
is defined as the heritability
and you can also
[Music]
define it in terms of as i've done here
selection intensity which is related to
the proportion of the population that
you select
if you select a very small proportion of
your starting population
you have a strong selection intensity
and you have the additive standard
deviation
the additive genetic standard deviation
that is and you have the selection
accuracy
so these are the parameters that you can
work with in your breeding program
to improve your response to selection
and as you just saw the
selection and cures that we had in our
spring out breeding program are steroids
we couldn't really expect any response
to selection at all
and of course this is another way to
view it
it's just a simple randomly generated
uh distribution of let's say of a trait
in an f4 population the white bars here
ten thousand lines now if you select
out of those ten thousand one hundred
lines randomly
and you produce an f7 the population
eventually for example
then the distribution in that f7
population will look as a small red
distribution at the bottom here
the mean will not be different from the
mean of the
big white s4 population but i will be
by chance of course some lines that are
slightly better
and some lines that are slightly worse
and if
then you select the lines that are
slightly better
[Music]
and use those as parents for your next
reading cycle then
you will have a small uh selection
differential
uh and you will have a small response in
the next generation
even if though you have selected at
random
you can have the response to selection
since
there will be some by chance some f7
lines that are better in some that are
worse and if you do good yield trials
with good preposition you
will be able to find those
however if you can select your in your
f4 lines you can select with an accuracy
of 0.5
you will have s7 lines with a much
larger with a
much higher mean than your original
population and
of course if you select the best of
those to be parents for your next green
cycle
then you will have a larger selection
differential and a larger response
so that is why it's so important to have
uh
you know good selection accuracy in
early generations
and of course
[Music]
we who work in commercial plant reading
we also
of course focus quite a lot on the
duration of the breeding cycle and the
gain
the selection response per unit time of
its genetic gain per unit time
and that depends on as we have seen
before the selection intensity
the selection accuracy the additive
genetic variation for examination
case and the duration of the breeding
cycle
which is in the denominator here
and if you do some simulations or you
can also look at this analytically
you see that the parameters with the
largest
effect on gain that you can play around
with
is for are the selection or the
generation interval or the
duration of the breeding cycle and the
accuracy of
selection intensity
and the amount of variance you have has
a
comparatively smaller effect on the gain
per unit time so we decided to work with
generation intervals or duration of the
breeding cycle
and the accuracy of collection to
improve
to get the most out of our challenge
improvement basically
and of course you know that in uh
in most breeding programs today the
breeding cycle are far
too long they can be up to
seven eight nine years
uh and the reason for that is of course
that if you select
the parents for your next cycle you must
be able to
base that selection on something and
normally
you base that selection on the
performance in yield trials
and you cannot do yield trials until you
are in the advanced generations it
usually takes
seven five six seven eight years for
that reason
you get very long breeding cycle cycles
if you have been able to select your
parents already in the early generation
then you would have a much shorter
reading cycle
and a much larger game per time but of
course
there is not much data to base your
selection of parents
on in most cases
unless of course you can use genetic
markers
and so
the question is can we use genetic
markers and there is certainly no
shortage of markers around i mean this
is a this is the timeline of
photogenic market development implants
and
breeding and started already now 30
years ago with with rfps
and now the same person would do work
with rfps today
in plant breeding it was not really
until
the pcr technology allowed us to to
generate thousands of markers hundreds
of markers and thousands
you have the rapid market eventually got
the
micro satellites markers we had afop
markers
and then we had dark markers which is
some kind of the
array-based paperbase more or less
and you could do qtl maps there were
association mapping you started a lot of
that was done
and now they you have clipper race you
also have
the frequency on our entire genome which
has
become cheaper and
practically feasible nowadays
and right now we have you know most of
the major crops have been
have been sequenced the wheat the barley
rye
oats has been done rapeseed is done
many other crops
we also have genomic frequencies of the
of the more or less good resolution
quality
but they are there
and of course uh there's
as i said there's no lack of markers to
be used in terms reading what was
missing
was some kind of theoretical
or conceptual or methodological
framework
to use markers in a good way in plant
breeding
and that's happened you could say with
the advent of genomic selection
and usually you take this public the
publication of this
paper into year 2000 as a starting point
of genomic selection
or in 2001 it was not an entirely new
idea at the time
there had been similar ideas around for
a while
but this was the first time that someone
really sort of formulated
a coherent idea of genomic collection
and this was
of course looking at
[Music]
animal breeding first and the support to
say
that here that it was concluded that
selection and genetic values predicted
for markets could substantially increase
the rate of genetic gain
in animals and plants especially if
combined with reproductive
the generation interval so they
realized that selection accuracy
and with green cycle time were the
important
parameters here
now if you're not familiar with genomic
selection
this is a very short sort of
course in genomic selection at the heart
of genomic selection is a prediction
model
which is a statistical device that
allows you to predict
phenotypes basically or breeding values
from genetic marketing
and what you need to
to build a prediction model is some kind
of data and you get that data from a
trading population
that from which you collect phenotypes
and you collect genotypes
then you take that and you build your
prediction model
and then you go to your breeding
population
then you genotype your brain population
and you
plug those genotypic data into your
prediction model
and you can predict phenotype
it's a very simple concept really even
though the statistics
behind it uh can be extremely
complicated and also
the question of how to apply genomic
selection in a practical
breeding program can be challenging
[Music]
so genomic selection is different from
from what we
usually call a marker assistant
selection that is
to use small supermarkets maybe just one
mark or a few markers to
do tagged trades in a breeding program
and that idea has been around
around since the markets were invented
since the isofine era really in the
1980s
and the reason one of the main reasons
why market assistance selection really
hasn't taken off that much in plant
breeding is that
it's really not useful for highly
polygenic traits traits that are
controlled by hundreds of genes
[Music]
that can't be handled by markers system
selection whereas they are
sort of made for genomic selection more
or
less
a marker assisted selection furthermore
you have to detect first
your market rate associations you have
to develop some kind of
mapping population either by current
population
or a association mapping panel or
something like that
whereas in genomic selection you just
don't it's just implicit in the model
but
somewhere in your data there is an
association
there is a linkage between some of your
markers at least
and on the tree
uh usually miss the minor qgl's when you
do
uh market trade association studies um
in uh selection units well that's maybe
a
more philosophical way of looking at it
but
usually you select you build the
genotype
basically in genomic collection but you
build
you collect the good genes in a line or
a variety
and what is most important i think is
that really
genomic selection allows you to make
significant reductions
in reading cycle time and that has large
effect as we have seen on genetic change
of course if you read magazines like
this you will have seen that
genomics has been very very
valuable in animal breeding
the value of cows have increased a lot
you can see here on the top right that
the average well that's the average gain
and it's not genetic gain it's it's a
monetary gain per year has increased a
lot since
the introduction of genomic selection in
encounter breeding
and also that the generation interval
has gone down particularly for both
since uh you can't really
phenotype both many traits such as milk
production for example you have to
be in fact the offspring the daughters
and that takes a long time and if you
can do it with
with a genomic prediction instead you
save a lot of time you can have a
much shorter generation
so it has had a significant effect in
animal breeding
but the concreting has been slower to
take up
genomic selection and
impractical plant-breeding programs
and uh they've been being questioned if
genomic selection has a future at all
when plant breeding these are two
animal breeding researchers in sweden
that
wrote this paper a couple of years ago
uh and the reasons i asked that question
is that
animal and plant breeding are quite
different
in their how they are structured and
built up
uh this is
from a publication by from john hickey a
couple of years ago animal breeding
animal breeding you focus quite a lot on
uh population improvement rapid
recurrent selection cycles
and from which it's illustrated by this
the wheel on top of the pyramid there
to to the to your left so rapid cycles
of the
mating selection mating selection
amazing selection and then
from that cycle you sort of extract
uh the producers the animal that's
actually going to produce the milk of
the meat or whatever it is
whereas whereas plant breeding has
focused quite a lot
particularly for cereals in breadcrumbs
online development the slow
process of inbreeding and development of
inbred lines extensive field testing
and very slow
[Music]
breathing cycles really
and for this reason uh
animal breeders have been more focused
on
quantitative genetics quantitative
genetic approaches to their work
uh things like project testing
estimation of breeding values
uh mixed model analysis all that stuff
i've seen sort of the routine work for
animal breeders
whereas plant breeding has sort of
drifted more and more into the hands of
agronomy
uh particularly you know as i said the
extensive field testing
things like that
or at least in in europe that has become
uh
so the plant breeding has become a job
for agronomists
to a large extent and many agronomists
do not have solid statistical training
it's not in europe
so
[Music]
genetic knowledge has
[Music]
which i think is one reason why
suddenly when this genomic selection
bomb explodes in the case of plant
breeders i don't
really know what to do with it um
because they're not really trained to
think in those terms
and it's also at least from my
experience
working now almost 15 years in practical
bank reading there are other reasons
which are more emotional than rational
uh when it comes to accepting things
like genomic selection and that's
something i call the cultural psychology
of something
because if you for example if you google
plant reader
and you look at your image results you
typically find something like this
this is a typical plant breeder you know
someone looking
in the field or in the greenhouse
looking intensely at the crop
in this case if
that image is exactly or
not very far removed from the image you
can see in 1912 100 years ago
even though at that time it was mostly
men who looked intensely at
something in this case i think about
here
and this is how many people at least in
europe tend to think about plant
breeders
and nowadays i think this
is a modern day plant breeder and we
just
last week hired a person a plant breeder
to sit in front of the computer
most of the time and develop prediction
models i think it's the first fan
breeder in our company that
will not have to wear boots
so there's a cultural shift here and
at least in my experience the our plan
predecess has a hard time accepting this
now let me just finish by giving you
some quick examples from
how we built up genomic selection how we
built up the old training program
uh using genomic collection i
can't go into uh the most secret details
here but i will
try to give you an idea at least of how
we were thinking
so we had this oats 2.0 the the
old-school breeding
traditional breeding setup where we had
earlier generations in the field and
then
i walked up and down here and selected
the best ones and what i thought were
the best ones
turned out they were not for this one
and then we did the yield trials
it was slow it was evidently inefficient
and it had what i call the low
information content
by which i mean that we didn't really
learn very much
by walking up and down this field every
from year to year
[Music]
so we replaced those early generations
with greenhouse grown single siege uh
propagated
light material and
we genotyped every single one of them
and we based our selection on
uh predicted phenotypes
we were able to do to go from cross
to field trials to to what you see on
the right
in three years so in year
one we did the cross in year three we
had the field
trials and we still do the field trials
because
one we have to validate our
our predictions and to
the final test will always be a
phenotypic test
uh and also we use the information from
the field
trials to update our prediction model so
it's a it's a continuous updating our
our models
are used in the sales trial which means
that we also put
bad stuff in the in the things lines we
know will never become a variety
we put in the yield class because we
need the data
and so this is uh
[Music]
one example it's now
one or two years old the accuracy of
uh predicted yield so on the
y-axis the vertical axis you have
predicted grain yield
in the f4 and on the image to the left
you will see the f4 generation that is
where
that material we did the prediction
and then then two years later we had the
f8 population in the field
and we could compare the predicted
phenotypes or the predicted yield
with the observed deals we have what we
think a pretty good correlation here
the cost per line of genotyping was at
that time 25 dollars
and it's interesting to compare to this
graph
on your left hand side now
again in that graph you have the
observed grade
yield in the f8 of the x-axis
and on the y-axis you have instead the
observed grain yield
the year before in the very same lines
and the accuracy of what we can call a
phenotypic prediction
and the accuracy of a genomic prediction
are well they're they're the same
they're equally good
just that the phenotypic prediction
costs
six times as much and you cannot do it
you have you cannot do it too much later
in the process
and of course the breeder's prediction
was zero so that's pretty useless
what else can we predict we can predict
the number of traits here
all those traits that i couldn't predict
and we can now predict
with markers instead
now of course you see a variation in in
the prediction accuracy between
different traits
and that probably has to do with with
the genetics of those traits
[Music]
some traits we get very uh good strong
uh
accurate predictions that's concept for
example which is
more or less impossible to see in the
field with the eye
we can predict with a with a high
probability or a higher accuracy
and also these are some examples from
spring wheat
which is bread a crop that we breed
for baking quality and baking quality
is something that's built up of many
different
sub traits because they down yield a
bread volume and glucose and index and
falling number and sedimentation and
all those stuff that are
absolutely impossible to observe in the
field but with an eye
which we can now predict using markers
and steps
with a good enough accuracy we think
and of course this is not i mean
everything we did was very home-cooked
but we made it up ourselves more or less
but i mean this has been
corroborated in many studies it's just
one example of a big study
in wheat more or less a global study
week
that has shown that you can predict a
large number of trades with
with very good accuracies i mean around
0.5.6 for for many
even complex trades so
[Music]
it's not what we see in our breaking
program it's not an artifact it's it's
for real and we need this uh sort of
evidence to be able to
convince our readers the more
traditionally minded ones that
economic selection is actually very very
promising
way of doing reading finally i just want
to mention that we can also
work on predicting crosses of course
in the old school plant reading in that
region 2.0
uh cross prediction which means which
parent shall i combine which mom should
i cross with which dad
was pretty much up to breeder guesswork
you could have two high yielding parents
for example but you wouldn't know if
they had complementary yield alleles or
genes or if they had the same ones and
the same ones
there would be no points in crossing
them if they had complimentary ones
there would be a point across them of
course you could have recommend
transgressive segregation in the
offspring
and so it's the reason why you do uh
hundreds and hundred different classes
each year is that you
simply don't really know which ones to
cost
uh uh and it has
even become a bit of a status along
each year how many do you do and if you
then only do 300 classes each year
say that uh
but if you think about it we we release
maybe one or two
new oat varieties each year
and if the merit of those varieties
is is due to genetics
then it is in principles predictable
knowable which crosses we should make so
it should it could be
sufficient sufficient for doing just one
or two crosses each year
and we try to increase sort of
the knowability or the prediction the
predictability of crosses
that we use by the stimulating classes
so nowadays or up to now we could do
about a couple of hundred lines
a couple of hundred combinations and a
couple of hundred progeny per
combination
and we would have some maybe ten
thousand or fifty thousand
offspring like the ones in the roast in
the field i showed you before
that would be uh evaluated by visual
inspection
nowadays we can simulate to do the
crossing in silicon this graph is an
example
we have here 3500 something like that
lined with snip data
that gives you about six million
pairwise combinations
that you can do in silicon not in
reality we have simulated 500 offspring
per combination so each dot you see is
mean value of 500
offspring 6 million crosses so we have
evaluated around 3 billion offspring
for a number of trades here all the
trades that we have prediction models
for
basically and on in the graph you have
on the x
axis here the yield and on the y axis
you have the volume weight for example
two important trades and then you can
select which crosses
you want to make and then here in this
particular example you have to do some
cradles between yield and volume weights
and it's just up to you know
your priorities which classes you want
to make here
but it does give you the possibility of
doing
uh billions of classes in in the
computer before you actually do them in
reality and so
the consequence of this
development from the implementation of
dynamic prediction models in breeding
has led us to structuring our
plant breeding in a way that is more
animal breathing like
sorry sorry
so now we have divided
[Music]
before i should say twin 2.0 is
what you see on the right hand side here
there's the
typical pedigree reading program
structure
now you are building up a
process to do what the animal breeders
do
the population improvement part which is
a rapid
cycling and prediction
selection cycles
so you cross you predict you select
across your predicted select
very quickly and you should if you
combine that with speed breathing
techniques
uh uh growing in your plan
growth chambers under very controlled
circumstances you can have
four up to six generations a year
which means that you can reduce your
green cycle even to below a year
and from that cycle from that wheel
we extract their lines to go into the
ordinary traditional yield trials
for the final selection of varieties but
also to provide
data for the prediction models and so
now atlanta we have
actually organized ourselves in two
groups
that we call variety development groups
that are populated mostly by agronomists
and they work with
all our different crops and they do the
field trials and they do
the final you know selection of the
varieties
and all that and we have one group
which is we call the population
improvement groups
group which is now
where statistical geneticists work
and they spend their time doing
prediction models basically
and uh i am sort of heading
uh that group right now and uh we are
so many people but we are we were hiring
more people over the years because
as more and more of our crops fit
into this scheme we will work more and
more on population improvement
for the two-part queening program
and to be a bit from
take some big words in my mouth i can
see that i think the genomic prediction
is really the grand union card theory of
genetic improvement
it's something that cuts across crops
you're not sort of in your cross silo
any longer you're not
expert or weak expert or bond expert you
can work across crops you can even
work across
[Music]
the plant animal divide
so we need a lot more of a lot more
people
statistical geneticists
bioinformaticians people like that
i think have a bright future in both
animal and plant breeding
and to me that's very exciting it's very
promising
for the future and
that's without it i want to stay today
thank you very much
thank you elf very interesting um
i can open up the floor for questions
now
um if you wish you can put your
questions in the chat box
or you can just raise your hand and
speak up
alpha i had a question about
um la manan
um i know you work on several crops but
do you typically have just one breeder
per crop or do you often have
more than one breeder per crop
well we have mostly one wheel
crop we have so in wheat for example we
have one
green wheat and one winter wheat flour
so that's two weeks two week readers
basically
then we have two barley burritos as well
other than that are typically one
breeder
and how many testing stations do you
have in sweden
and in in europe
in sweden we have well
first of all we have our own stations 3d
stations
and we have uh
sweden it's not a very big country so we
have three
you know three breeding stations that we
own in sweden
and one breeding station that we own in
the netherlands
and then we sort of use service
providers for other
for the other locations so we have
in oats for example we have i think
some 15 to 20 location across europe and
we have
five or six locations in canada and uh
i'm not sure exactly the other crops how
many they have but
something similar i guess
so we try not to own too much land but
we try to buy
services from
uh well trial service providers
every university in general to be a
private company
i i had a question about uh about
seed increasing when you're using this
rapid uh
when you're growing a bunch of cycles by
single seed descent in the greenhouse
how then do you move quickly from
the single seed or the spike or the
panicle if you're
doing oats how do you move from that to
an fc to plant out a yield plot
is that done in the greenhouse or is
that done with a summer season or a
counter season nursery
the combination actually so when we
harvest the final
single seed generation we
uh plant that in the greenhouse in
in the soil in the greenhouse so we get
we do some kind of hill clocks in the
greenhouse
and uh so
the final thing you'll see the sun
generation is harvested in
february march the plant is
called greenhouse hill club in april
we harvest them in in august we send
them to new zealand
and the year after we can get enough
feedback to
plan year trials at six locations
thank you we've had we've had good
experience with new zealand seed
increases as well
we've got yeah we get we've we've gotten
up to 100 to 1
seed increase in new zealand
do you have any problems do you ever
have any problems with seed dormancy
when you're trying to
turn over generations in your greenhouse
no well um well i don't know
it works very well
mark there are a couple questions now in
the chat oh sorry oh yeah thanks
uh yes there are a couple of questions
in the chat box um
from nick morales it says thanks for the
talk is the genotyping done
in-house and how many snips do you
generally work with
right now the genotyping is a certain
person we buy
[Music]
we work you know with a chip
that has about we typically get much
5000 or so polymorphic
nets
even though there are more on the jet
we are building up now our capacity to
work
in-house with genotyping so we would
move to inaudible
which would probably be some kind of
sequence in the fight
another question um from john luke
yannick thank you for this talk are you
still in a phase where you are rapidly
evolving your breeding schemes in
response to the new prediction
opportunities
or do you feel that you are reaching a
new equilibrium
hmm that's a very good question
[Music]
i well we're
getting to an equilibrium i think when
we started
in 2014 with genomic selection
it was as a way of
doing early generation selection as i
tried to show
since then we have moved more and more
to cross stations
and trying very hard to reduce the
breeding cycle
and we can accept i mean if you have a
very
fast breeding cycle you can accept the
lower prediction occurrences
so uh but i think
the actually the old treaty program is
beginning to mature at this now
because we still have we have other
crops that are more challenging
and the forage crops and you know
hybrids and the
cloning crops and stuff like that we
have not come
as far with the uh
the oats and the streams
so and we don't know how they will help
those breeding programs we look in the
end
john luke also asked if are you worried
about loss of genetic diversity with
rapid
cycles yes we are
concerned with that we have to keep an
eye
on that of course and
i mean one time
if you don't lose in adequate variation
you should be worried
because then your selection is not
sufficient enough
uh but of course you will
if you have a very efficient selection
you will lose an expiration you have to
replenish that somehow
and i don't think we have really settled
our mind exactly on how
that should be done have to carry out
simulations and
trials and things like that we're
experimenting quite a lot here
all the time
you know that's uh how we learn also
okay we are getting short on time
um so i think
we'll wrap it up there alf and just want
to
thank you very much for your
presentation and please give my re
regards to pernilla vollendock
for those in the audience pernillo uh
vollenbach was is a as a
acquaintance uh that uh that
uh she and i thought that it would be
good idea to
to learn more about the landmannan
breeding program and so
uh alf graciously agreed to give this
presentation
um pernilla is is one of the breeders at
la
manum so with that i'm gonna
say thank you again and we'll wrap up
this presentation
uh thanks again elf and so long
everybody
thanks for having me
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu